[Music]
hey everybody
it's
what [ __ ] day is it tuesday tuesday
it's getting to that point in my life i
don't know what [ __ ] day it is well
we're working from home so it doesn't
matter what day it is i mean it kind of
does because i have to know what day it
is so so i know what we're doing that
day and what i got to upload and all
that other stuff all the days are kind
of the same
[Laughter]
soon you die yeah
right all right so this one was called
psycho gorman
or psycho gourmand if you prefer it was
a [ __ ] show
but it's a total [ __ ] show in a way
you're supposed to be it's supposed to
be a [ __ ] show
basically i saw
i had been seeing this recommended like
everywhere this is like a super super
fun movie this is definitely one you
want to kind of like get some drinks and
like have some friends over and like
watch this [ __ ] for this [ __ ] it's yeah
it's a comedy it's a horror comedy
it's basically like i saw some other
reviews of this and somebody in one of
the comments one of the videos said what
is essentially like the perfect
description they said this was as if
sam raimi had directed an episode of
power rangers yes i was just saying the
same thing i was going to say or
or if the monster squad starred gwar
yeah
it's kind of that's kind of like the
vibe
that is uh you know
it's uh
it's like
if the power rangers were were a horror
movie they had kids in it yeah
which is weird you know horror and kids
and [ __ ] the weird [ __ ] but that's
just just the way the movie is it had
some [ __ ] pretty cool costumes
you know like something out of guar
and uh
dialogue and stuff i kind of really
wasn't in the mood for it at the time
that i was watching it but i i kind of
appreciated it for what it was it it had
that power rangers tone mixed with a
bunch of gore
yeah [ __ ] weird [ __ ] i got a hell
razor and stuff
but funny but it's like funny it's funny
yeah it kind of reminded me you know
what it kind of reminded me of and i'm
glad somebody else uh had brought this
up in like a comment that i saw they
said this would make a good double
feature with turbo kid you remember that
movie that yeah this because it's it's
like a throwback like 80s 90s throwback
like saban
yeah it was like whereas turbo kid was
kind of more like a mad max type of
thing whereas this is more like a sci-fi
like i said more like a power rangers
type of thing um but they have like a
similar kind of tone a similar sense of
humor so i feel like the two of those
like if you like turbo kid you'd
probably like this one too yeah maybe
i can see where you're coming from turbo
kit was a lot better though
i think oh yeah i think turbo kit was a
lot better turbo kid was
mad max meets it was a superhero movie
set in a mad max world but kind of well
like mad max
more like a superhero movie in in in the
fallout universe
yeah from the video game fallout kind of
like that
um
it
and it was
like that movie was made in the 80s
yeah it had a lot of 80s tropes and [ __ ]
an 80s tone to it
this one is like
uh
i don't know if it was uh
i don't know if it was as expertly
written as as as turbo kid turbo kid was
good
real good this one is jus it is fun all
right
the tone's different the tone is very
different this is like a yeah i'm just
saying but it's along the same lines
kind of yeah i guess it's along the
thing if you want to say so i guess so
yeah i say
not really but kind of well and i'm like
i said i thought that while i was
watching that and then i was like
somebody else like in another comment
said that this would make it good not
that they're saying that they're like
exactly the same but it's just in the
sense of them being like good throwback
just fun throwback type of movies this
is
like a horror movie made by saban
yeah that's essentially what it's like
so this was uh it's interesting because
the guy that directed this uh steven
kastansky he also directed the void
which is actually a [ __ ] great movie
but the void is like totally totally
different to this one the void is more
like love crafty and horror kind of like
a thing type of thing and it's like kind
of serious but
in the sense that because uh i didn't
really know too much about this but
steven kastansky is one of
he there's like five or six uh canadian
guys and they have like a production
company called astron 6 and they're
super super into
um
old school like 70s 80s throwback movies
and they're super into practical effects
um so it's like directors uh you know
special effects guys and this uh
collective this film collective we're
also responsible for the movie the
editor which came out back in 2014 that
giallo parody remember we saw that on
shutter i loved that and actually the
guy that was in that like the main role
is in this movie too he actually plays
the dad i can't remember the actor's
name
but uh he's a great character in this
too he's not in it a bunch but because
this is mostly focused around the kids
and the monster but so what the story of
psycho gourmand is
is that essentially there's it's like i
said it's a very power rangers type of
story whereas
um the main monster
who doesn't really have a name he's kind
of has all these different names like
archduke of nightmares and stuff and
he's like an intergalactic evil
dude right basically xenu
yeah kinda
he's kind of like that
so there's this like intergalactic
council
uh led by this group called the templars
and they have
sort of imprisoned him and he's
imprisoned on earth
so there's these two kids mimi and her
brother luke
and they play this game in their
backyard called crazy ball and the one
that loses has to bury the bury
themselves alive or something like that
so while they're digging up in the back
backyard they essentially find this
jewel and they find the you know the
kind of the grave so they let this
monster out
now this monster
who doesn't have a name at the beginning
is basically like just wants to kill
everybody and everything because he's
like just
essentially just an evil being right
but uh problem being the little girl
mimi who is like this terrible
sociopathic
obnoxious child but also very funny she
has this gem
that whoever possesses this gem can tell
the monster what to do like he has to
obey like they're every so this little
girl
totally totally abuses
this power yeah now these all these
aliens look like something out of them
power rangers or yeah
yeah type stuff they're big foam rubber
outfits uh the
outfits are really good looking you know
they're pretty cool
um and it's all practical effects
um
now when i said it pretty cool they're
about like what they were power rangers
yeah or
well and you can tell they were that's
what they were kind of homaging yeah you
know what i mean they didn't really want
them to look real they just wanted them
to look kind of just cool just cool and
you know or kind of like also the guyver
if you guys have seen the guy yeah and
actually the guy that directed it did
say that he was really the particularly
the sequel to the guyver um that he
really that was kind of where his main
inspiration for this story was yeah
it's good yeah it is what it is you know
if you're in if you like that kind of
[ __ ] you'd like this movie it's a trip
yeah and like i said it's just like a
really fun you know there's there's
musical kind of cues in there because
they make like they the the little girl
like gives him the name psycho gourmand
because she thinks that's like the
coolest name like pg for short that's
what she calls him but they come up like
that's one of the funniest scenes when
they first find him and she finds out
that she can control him and they try to
come up with like all this the most
badass sounding games that they can come
up with and it's like and the fact that
essentially it comes to a thing where
you know he's
obviously he doesn't like being
controlled by this um cruel obnoxious
little girl
but there isn't really anything he can
do about it and just the juxtaposition
the funny [ __ ] too is that i'm not
really sure if this is supposed to be
set i almost feel like it was supposed
to be set like in the 80s or 90s i don't
think they really say
um but it didn't look like anybody had
cell phones or anything like that um and
the way some of the clothes were it
looked like
80s or maybe early 90s
so i'm not really sure like it doesn't
super matter or anything but the
funniest thing about it is like there's
like the most bonkers [ __ ] happens like
there's one thing where the little girl
mimi has a crush on her brother's friend
alistair
and um
basically she she wants to make like
psycho gorman like fall in love with her
or something but psycho gorman doesn't
really understand love or anything
because he's just like an evil being so
he essentially turns alistar into this
big brain blob kind of creature and it's
like he just this little blob just kind
of like goes around and everyone just
acts like it's normal like he's like a
normal kid like no one says hey he's
like a brain flop
and it's like [ __ ] like that is just
like funny to me and the the fact i
think that
this there's just these crazy like
ridiculous situations it's just silly
but yeah that's what i mean it's a goofy
movie but it's supposed to be goofy it's
just supposed to be a funny that's fun
that's its deal if you think it's over
the top then no it's not over they're
gonna even go above that yeah because
it's just like just ridiculous
just ridiculous situations but like i
said that's kind of where the humor
comes from is just that the [ __ ] just
like ramps up and gets sillier and
sillier and
uh psycho gourmand is just basically
like i'm going to kill you all and i was
in the little girl's like yeah i don't
think so blah blah blah and then just
like so so there are all that [ __ ] going
on and then there's also
um you know the the galactic council
has sent like one of the templars to
earth
to basically fight him because he's
escaped and they want to like get him
contained again so he doesn't [ __ ] up
the whole universe so it's basically
there's this whole thing where
the little girl has almost kind of like
befriended him but he's still evil so
it's like she has to decide and she's
like i said the little girl is like
pretty much a psychopath too she's like
not a good guy by any stretch of the
imagination uh and she like abuses the
[ __ ] power that she has big time
but it's kind of like she
she's kind of willing to let
to let psycho gourmet just like run
run riot all over the earth and like
kill people
just because it's just like i don't know
it's like a [ __ ] crazy ass story you
get to see little kids blown up uh
people's heads get pulled off and it's
just i think the best thing about this
it almost seems like what's cool about
this and i didn't know this either but
one there's a bunch of um
action figures because like i said all
these characters seem like they're just
like ready made for action figure type
stuff because they're all so cool
looking and all the members of the
intergalactic council or whatever it is
um you know all look completely
different uh my favorite one was the one
with that was just like the small and
then he was like kind of a brain with
eyeballs like inside yeah yeah yeah
um and there's also like a vinyl record
that's like blue and pink that's like
kind of but
another thing that's cool though is that
the guys that made this movie they
essentially wrote even though a lot of
it's not in the movie they wrote a whole
entire backstory for not only psycho
gourmand but also every single member of
the council and you don't like see any
of that in the movie but they just did
this whole rich like they just built
this whole world
um
and you know not even putting it in the
movie so i don't know
if this is eventually going to be like a
franchise type of thing because it seems
like something that could be because
it's a very wide
you know the world of it is very large
but part of the joke is that psycho
gorman when he comes to earth and he's
like this eternal being and he's like
trying to tell the kids like he's trying
to
convey to them like how evil and what a
badass he is so he's trying to tell like
all these stories about like all this
stuff he did and the kids are just like
don't care you know what i mean because
they're all like atd and everything so
it's like that's kind of part of the
funny [ __ ] but
so you only get like little snippets of
his history but apparently he has this
whole entire backstory if you go to the
website for this this is just like all
kind of like crazy
um you know supplementary material which
i think is like really cool because they
really put a lot of thought into it
but yeah um i think it's funny because
this came on shutter i think it was
supposed to come out
back in march of 2020
um at uh maybe south by southwest i want
to say but um you know since they didn't
have the the festival that year it kind
of got pushed back and then shutter
picked it up uh early this year so they
premiered it in some theaters and then
they premiered it um back in january of
this year i think and i've been seeing
like a lot of horror channels covering
it and then the other day i was watching
um you know that girl i like jade the
libra that does all the halloween decor
and uh she has some of her videos are
sponsored by shutter and she was talking
about how much her and her husband liked
this movie and uh so i was like oh man
yeah i should probably get around to
watching that because it sounds super
funny so i finally got around to
watching it and like i said you talk you
know
like tom said you definitely have to be
in the mood to watch this because it's
it's really goofy and it's really silly
but
it's meant to be goofy and silly like i
said if you're into like if you want to
see something that's essentially like a
gory version of the power rangers um
with similar kind of outfits and similar
kind of situations then you will
probably really really dig this uh
because that's pretty much exactly the
vibe that it's going for it's it's
interesting that you mentioned the
guyver too because i think the director
himself even brought that up
that um
specifically the guyver 2
which i haven't seen in a really long
time but um he said that was uh pretty
much a direct inspiration for this movie
um so if i mean if that sounds like
something and like i said it's got since
it's focused on kids it's got like a lot
of kind of monster squad type of vibe to
it as well
and like like i said kind of a guar type
of thing um but yeah it's just like a
big dumb fun
sci-fi action comedy they achieved with
gore
yeah all right it wasn't really to my
taste yeah if i saw it again maybe in a
different frame of mine probably like a
little bit better it was it was silly it
is it is very simple i see what they
were doing i think it'll be successful
it may be well i mean yeah i mean it has
been like i said pretty much every
horror uh
every horror channel i've seen is like
really really dug this and it seems like
on you know rotten tomatoes or whatever
it has like 91 92 something like that
but like yeah you have to go into it
knowing that it's a comedy if you're in
a good mood and you were drunk this
would be [ __ ] great that's what i
mean this is definitely a movie that you
know have some friends over get
plastered and just watch
the ridiculousness because it's just
super super funny i think pretty much
one of the only criticisms because the
only thing that's divisive about this it
seems like is that some people really
didn't like uh mimi's character because
they thought she was too annoying but
even though like the character her
character's supposed to be annoying
she's supposed to be an obnoxious little
brat
who essentially
you know through no uh just through
complete accident gets you know the
complete power of evil in the universe
like placed in her hands and totally
[ __ ] abuses it um so she's supposed
to be a little [ __ ] so it's like you're
not really supposed to like her but i
think she's still like um a funny
character just like the funny situations
in this like the one like where the cop
gets melted it's just there's just like
[ __ ] funny lines the whole thing
about
um them bringing psycho gourmand like uh
magazines and [ __ ] the little girls like
look it's got hunky boys in it and then
psycho gourmet's like i'm not into hunky
boys or am i
it's like just this kind of like [ __ ]
it's just like it had some great
one-liners like i said the dude that was
in the editor that is also that plays
the dad in this he's a [ __ ] great
character like he's just this
lazy
useless dad type of character who just
like doesn't know anything it doesn't do
anything and it's just
his character is like super funny and
just the interactions between him and
his like fed up wife are very funny also
so there's like a lot of other stuff
going on this like the family dynamic
and everything but it's just you know
him turning that kid into a brain and
like no one's saying anything about it
and everyone just acting like it's
normal that just like really cracked me
up but yeah so it's it's that kind of
movie it's just like a fun goofy
like i said if you if you like turbo kid
or some if something in that line uh
this is probably wackier goofier than
that but you know if you like like
throwback kind of [ __ ] then you should
definitely give it a watch and because
it seems like most people are like kind
of into it
um
what
what oh somebody was like samus yeah
yeah unfortunate almost like zaran uh
just views for now i can't do super chat
so i send gifts to help the channel
yeah well you know um all right tom
needs to make a book of quotes
i think we didn't we talk about that at
some point i feel like a long time i
forgot them all though we were yeah
that's the thing recording any of this
[ __ ] in my mind it just comes out and
it's like sometimes i guess we could do
it because you know obviously i you know
i have all the live streams and stuff
but i would have to it would take me
like a million hours to go back and
listen to everything and like write down
everything that you said yeah because
sometimes you do say some like really
funny [ __ ] and i'm like oh i should
write that down but then i forget what
it was it's a constant stream of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] basically
well just like say stupid well see
that's what that's why you have all the
poltergeist action happening yeah and
[ __ ] like that yeah which i keep telling
the polter guys to to put a million
dollars in my paypal yeah if you got if
you guys missed that [ __ ] we talked
about that yesterday [ __ ] i got the
key back
yeah the key [ __ ] came yeah in case
you weren't here yesterday yeah he came
back the poltergeist brought the key
back yeah and and put it in pookie's
paws it was a trip like just randomly
and just out of no just boom well yeah
because she was laying there and she
didn't have the key and then suddenly
she had the key
she ran back through jumped on her back
and went like that left to play and then
i noticed that she was chewing on the
key
yeah and there's nowhere she could have
got it it's crazy yeah well like i said
anybody like a poltergeist that could do
that i'm talking about it like it's a
separate entity but it kind of is a
poltergeist that could do that would
certainly have no problem
taking one single dollar from a million
people's bank accounts putting them in
my bank account like in a way that can't
be traced to me so i don't get in
trouble yeah just saying that you know a
poltergeist could do that
yeah
it happened because i thought because i
was blaming phuket that maybe she ran
off with the key yeah so it framed her
yeah
see she had it the whole time
but she was in an area she doesn't pick
things up or take them very far
and she wasn't in an area where it could
have been i turned that whole area
upside down and she didn't have it two
seconds before i looked away and looked
back and she had it and she had it like
in her little paws like she was on the
back on yeah i have a new toy
we wondered if like the poltergeist just
dropped it out of midair and she just
caught it it didn't scare her
well she doesn't care she was not yeah i
got a key
she probably well i said yesterday she
probably like sees [ __ ] ghosts all
the time and she's just like oh whatever
i don't think she's i i don't think she
questioned it i think it just fell out
and it fell out of somewhere and she got
it and it just started chewing on it
yeah but she didn't have it
she ran
i was just wrestling with her and she
ran
she got up and ran about three feet
turned right around and [ __ ] ran
right towards me and jumped on her back
and put her feet up in the air and
[ __ ] i looked down to grab her
because i could see her do that at the
corner of my eye
and pick him
i reached down and grabbed her to
continue playing with her and i noticed
that she had the key yeah
that's pretty it's crazy yeah four throw
down remembered one of your quotes
hookers cannot resist crack in fact of
course not
that must have been when we were talking
about frank and hooker yeah
that's not a quote that's a universal
law
gravitation
yeah
yeah hookers and crack
uh yeah david june says as i said you
defeated boss pookie and everyone knows
the boss of the level has the key
[Laughter]
she i just it's just like that's
mystifying it's mystifying yeah and like
i said it was so funny that you just
like came i didn't know what your deal
was you just came in my office yesterday
going nope no no no no and i was like
what the hell is your problem i think he
puts the key down somebody uh michael he
said a gift would be arriving day from
ups
okay oh thank you very much all right oh
it may be out there on the on the wheel
oh no it's only 3 21. ups can comes
pretty late sometimes yeah i don't know
why like you pizza like our mail comes
like between like 2 and 3 30 but like
ups usually doesn't come till six or
seven louie comes up with
at least it's a movie tom ross yeah
that's what i was gonna make a shirt of
that at least it's a movie well that's
something
yeah
oh my god yeah
uh but yeah so what else do we have to
talk about anything
oh no that's it yeah you don't want to
talk about anything else no
no
he's in a mood yeah i'm gonna go walk oh
okay well and i have to say too that we
already we we recorded um a review today
yeah we've been working already for the
craziest and then and then i recorded a
review earlier too for a movie that for
one that i'm putting up on saturday yeah
so
my little voice is going and i'm thirsty
so it's tuesday which means that
tomorrow tomorrow is another [ __ ]
thing my liver is already going oh
no
are we out of booze no i got black
velvet oh okay that's right yeah oh
that's right i forgot we had like yeah i
got black phil he went to sam's and got
all the [ __ ] all the beer yeah i just
didn't know if we had it okay so we will
probably be drinking beer tomorrow night
yeah we can you know
we're running low on vodka we could get
some of that too i get we get paid
tonight i get paid tonight yeah it's the
third yeah it's the last day of august
hooray
i mean it's still gonna be hot for like
it's starting for like three months but
it starts to cool down psychologically
yeah um at least i was like well at
least technically sort of the summer is
over
you do start the temperature does start
coming down and every now and then you
will get a cool day over the next
although it's usually mornings like it's
usually like night or morning is
sometimes i just don't like that full
full-on full blast
floor to just [ __ ] satan's ass crack
[ __ ] hot and god and muggy i'm
telling you too it's like ever since you
started putting like giving me that test
yeah i swear to god i come back from
like doing my power walks and it's like
why do i smell like hot garbage yeah
like seriously i didn't smell that bad
before because the hormones
oh it's so bad yeah i just come back and
i'm like jesus christ yeah
you get that slimy kind of sticky sweat
that's awful yeah but i'm just i don't
know for you though
wait for the keep your metabolism
running i guess so yeah you know what i
mean yep oh i feel bad now hankster said
finally made a live i love your channel
thank you very much it's like we were
just about ready to
go i always feel really bad when that
happens when somebody like turns up yeah
uh yeah oh yeah the hurricane oh [ __ ]
man that didn't hit us no but i mean it
hit lots of other places yeah um didn't
it [ __ ] up they hit new orleans
new orleans is kind of like the apex of
all evil that god is constantly
punishing new orleans for its sins
going all the way i don't think god's
doing that i think just the way it's
situated just keeps doing that yeah and
honestly we shouldn't pirate city for
[ __ ] we shouldn't like talk too much
because i mean he's here too they hit
here too and like i said september and
october those are like the big hurricane
months yeah so what um the the the
people that built
new orleans [ __ ] hundreds of years
ago
didn't know much about [ __ ] nature
they built a lot of the [ __ ] on top of
[ __ ] cotton bales in the middle of a
[ __ ] swamp it was a pirate cove
really i can't see how this would ever
be a bad
idea then they ended up building a city
inside of a damn bowl
and real you know what i mean
outside a damn swamp right in the
[ __ ]
right in the middle of where a bunch of
hurricanes hit it was it's always been
cursed i mean that that city was never
supposed to be there but it's been there
for hundreds of years since the 1500s
or 1600s i think it was in the earth
because after a while they're just like
yeah bring it we'll just build it right
back it's not an american city with
spanish and french and uh i don't know
if england
england might have had a control for it
for a certain period of time and now
it's american and it's just
it shouldn't have been there you know i
mean there's a bunch of dykes and
[ __ ] levees that hold the [ __ ]
ocean back
they constantly fail
um
property isn't worth much there because
anything you build it's eventually going
to get destroyed just living there is a
bad idea
i was gonna i was gonna say it just
reminded me of um where where we walk
along the path there's a property over
there
that is uh well because i don't know
most of almost all of florida is right
at sea level
um
but some of the stuff you got to watch
because there's like flood zones yeah
and uh so there's this one house it
looks like it was probably built in the
50s or 60s and it has this giant
backyard seriously every time it rains
hard their whole backyard floods and it
basically turns into like a marsh for
several weeks because it takes like a
really long time for all the water to
drain all the birds and the frogs
[ __ ] love it um you know you go
walking and there's like this big
[ __ ] lake in these people's backyard
and there's all these like cranes
and little frogs and ducks and stuff and
it's just kind of like i'm like that
must suck another fair another weird
thing about new orleans is the [ __ ]
freeways
it's the [ __ ] it's like they were
built by [ __ ] drunken children
dropping acid
it around the cities nothing but just a
big bio a big [ __ ] swamp
and you have freeway lanes that go up on
their own and go up like [ __ ] 10
stories it seems like way over swamp
then they turn sideways and they just go
in these [ __ ] weird-ass random places
so you're constantly almost a little bit
like in an airplane when you're driving
and [ __ ] i used to drive down there
through shitty ass [ __ ] cars and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that'd
borrow from family members to go see my
[ __ ] cousins i'd be white knuckling
it you're in the air over a goddamn
[ __ ] swamp and you're like i know
[ __ ] cajuns built this [ __ ] man if
this [ __ ] falls i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
these [ __ ] they feel like the whole
thing's [ __ ]
moving like a damn roller coaster so
it's got the and and you're like why'd
they build it this way
it's crazy
you can see the [ __ ] on google earth
it's [ __ ] you'll be white knuckling
it over this and then you drive across
the damn causeway it's like it seems
like it's about 10 15 miles long
going across the ocean
and it's two lanes wide
uh
and it's just ocean on either side and
and you feel like the [ __ ] is that
thing's gonna fall into the ocean and it
did fall in the ocean during hurricane
katrina imagine if you were on that [ __ ]
and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] fell in the ocean they fixed it
yeah [ __ ] no no thanks i don't think
anybody was driving on it when when
katrina hit well because it probably
been evacuated it probably evacuated
uh kanavathalan asked what you thought
of oak island
oak island what's oak island that's that
one that's supposed to have like the
treasure down there and everybody keeps
adventures and everybody keeps like we
should probably do a show about that
they've done like a whole like reality
series about that it's kind of like that
whole like killing bigfoot or finding
bigfoot or whatever and it's just kind
of like how can you make like 10 seasons
of a show where you're actually not
finding the thing that you're supposed
to be finding so i kind of feel like the
oak island thing i don't think it's been
on for that i'm not sure actually i
don't remember where it's at i don't
think there's anything there i mean you
think so many people have been there
like they would have found some [ __ ]
trying to find pirate treasure
pirates didn't bury their treasure this
is a [ __ ] myth
maybe it happened once but they didn't
[ __ ] bury treasure
they divided it up amongst each other
and they ran off with their treasure and
[ __ ] you wouldn't it'd be like we're
going to leave the money here no that's
not how it works
yeah we'll come back for it we'll come
back for it later nobody will you know
we can trust y'all
no that's not how
[ __ ] you know
but um
i mean they were digging in there they
had companies that were trying to dig
and dig for pirate treasure
and it was uh it was
and it was filled with water and silt
and [ __ ]
and they may they were making money off
the dig okay because you could raise
money like crowd source of money to
continue to dig yeah and then when they
lose hope somebody go up there and throw
an old coin in the damn [ __ ] silt and
go oh look what we found we're almost
there and that was grif more money
it's a spanish doubloon
it's in here
we just need another million dollars to
continue digging
which would actually be a good idea if
you'd like dug there and you were gonna
like your money was gonna run out well
everything they supposedly dug up out of
there is questionable
it's people throwing coins in there in
the middle of the dig to justify yeah
because how easy would that be to do
yeah and then you're like encouraging
everybody
yay you know what i mean i wouldn't
trust anything
yeah like i said if there was anything
there they would have found it by now
yeah i mean honestly and and i'm not
saying there's if you want to look for
pirate treasure it's a lot more
expensive but you need to look in the
bottom of the [ __ ] ocean is where you
need to look yeah
where the ships go down i mean [ __ ] if
you go up to saint augustine they have a
pirate and treasure museum and they have
a whole little section of like [ __ ] that
they've done they got out of the ocean
that was from pirate ships there's like
some cool [ __ ] in there i heard some
preliminary [ __ ] remember the uh
remember that flight 19 of the [ __ ]
guys who
evidently you know they got abducted by
the ufo
evidently they found one of those planes
oh yeah that's right we were talking
about that not too long ago at the
bottom of the ocean well yeah where else
was it going to be it's not going to be
on [ __ ] mars it was right there where
it probably should have been they found
one of them in pieces i know i hate to
say it's usually it's usually something
very boring ran out of fl they ran out
of [ __ ] they ran yeah they just they
got lost and they're just like oh [ __ ] i
forgot what direction i was going in
yeah it's a bummer but you know yeah
florida beach is full of real traitor
yeah that's what i mean [ __ ] washes up
all the time there's like tons of
[ __ ] i mean tampa and all that it's
like over there in the gulf of mexico
there's [ __ ] all kind of like
treasure under there yeah from all the
ships that they haven't uh found yet all
right so
tomorrow night is wednesday it's the
side track show
so we'll get some drinks
and we'll talk about whatever [ __ ]
we normally talk about and everybody
will hang out and it'll be a super fun
time
so uh yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by today and we will see you guys
tomorrow evening